so how do you turn your knowledge and
experience Into Cash maybe you've been a
photographer for years a real estate
agent a service professional of some
kind you have experience you have
knowledge and you want to take that on
YouTube and start to monetize it you can
create a course a coaching program and
today talking to lloyda Velasquez who
was a real estate agent for years built
up her credibility built up all that
experience but also then transitioned
into creating content on YouTube and
creating products and programs to serve
clients and help them get results so
we're going to learn a little bit more
about her story and how you can
ultimately monetize in multiple
different ways different than YouTube
AdSense on your YouTube channel so
lloyda thanks for coming back on the
podcast yes I'm always excited to do
this Sean thank you so much for being
here and uh I'm excited so in part one
we talked really about how to use
YouTube for real estate agents which is
who you as a coach help but I'm actually
curious about a little bit of your story
you can go into that and but really your
transition from doing the thing and then
eventually teaching the thing yeah and
so uh speak to that Journey
what's funny is that when I was little I
wanted to be a teacher
um later on I grew up eventually you
know that thought went away so the fact
that I'm teaching now agents it kind of
brings me back and it's like a full
circle moment where I'm like you know
what I'm actually doing what I wanted
two years ago when I didn't even think
of it so the transition happened when I
was doing transactions I was actively
learning making calls door knocking
doing the things that a lot of Agents
don't want to do or have no idea where
to start and as I'm putting out this
content many of them are reaching out
because they want help and they wanted
me to show them the ropes and be
successful the way that I had been able
to do my thing so it happened in 2020
when the pandemic hit that's when I took
that as an opportunity to Crank It Up on
video because I was like this is the
time for me to show up a lot of agents
are probably going to leave the business
but I need to make sure that everyone
knows that I'm still in the business and
I'm still here to show you and teach you
whatever it is that you need in order to
succeed and to make it out of this that
no one knows what's going to happen so
that's when I created my new age at boot
camp in that boot camp initially it was
30 days and I would cover absolutely
everything from communication tonality
scripts objection handlers working with
buyer sellers so everything that any
agent needed to know to succeed it was
like a crash course and this is what you
need
everyone loved it I remember when I
created that I hadn't done anything like
that before and I told myself you know I
have 20 people sign up this is going to
be amazing I had 60 people so then the
next month I did it again and it was a
hundred people and I'm like you know
what I'm on to something here because
obviously there's a need that needs to
be fulfilled a lot of Agents aren't
getting this type of education and
what's funny is that while I'm doing
these boot camps some agents were
letting me know that their Brokers were
using my YouTube videos to train them so
as I'm creating this the boot camps I
saw that a lot of Agents were getting
success they would send me screenshots
they would say hey loyda I did that
thing that you said I got my first deal
I just got my first paycheck so that was
really fulfilling for me so I knew that
you know everything that I'm teaching
you is a hundred percent legit if you
implement it so if you implement it
you're going to have success so that led
on to coaching and seeing how I could
work more with agents that really wanted
to kick it up a notch if you're doing
you know 12 deals what are we going to
do to do 36 figures and and that type of
thing so that's kind of how how that
came about that's amazing and how long
were you in real estate but when did you
start
I started in 2015. so you're about five
years what would you give for advice for
somebody who's questioning their
expertise I we agree at think media that
you definitely should be we want to hold
ourselves to the standard of being
player coaches uh we don't want to be
teaching something we haven't lived and
done
um sometimes people think though that
five years does it does it need to be
five years does it need to be ten years
if someone's doubting their expertise
like when is it okay to present yourself
as a teacher and no one's going to ever
come and Knight you like at the Knights
of the Round Table James altucher wrote
a book called Choose Yourself at some
point you have to just say like you have
permission you have permission to do it
of course you want to have that
confidence and that credibility so if
you're thinking about someone that's
moving into coaching what's like a
framework to say okay I've done the
thing I have the experience now I'm
ready to teach from your perspective
I would see if there's maybe people that
you can teach what you know so that they
can implement it so you can already
start seeing results and have some type
of proof that what you're doing is not
just based on what you can do and your
knowledge but it can be duplicated by
anyone so do it on a small scale before
you maybe productize it that's actually
what we did with our program video
ranking Academy was I had a theory that
this would work and I started to give it
away for free in exchange for video
testimonials if the person liked the
program so before just sitting down and
like recording an online course or
launching a boot camp at least that's
what I did I said okay I know I can rank
videos can I help other people rank
videos yeah and so I actually started to
hit up just social media Friends Network
people who are maybe following me and
I'm talking about tech and cameras doing
the thing of uh doing affiliate
marketing built up to six figures
talking about cameras whatever and and
they then said uh okay sure so I got on
like Zoom meetings no product no program
yet and said hey do this do this do this
and then it also helped me kind of build
up some testimonials early on and so see
not only do the thing first
pass along your knowledge see if they
could get some results and then kind of
productize how did you
to come up with the name the product the
structure had you it was that the first
time you had done that it was the first
basically product that was the first one
yeah and what was it called again the
new agent bootcamp and so how from your
standpoint how did you sit down and
think about name marketing
you know structuring it
I'm the type of person that sometimes as
I'm thinking about it it all just comes
at once okay I was attracting a lot of
new agents because the content that I
was putting out is exactly what they
were looking for so I said you know what
I'm gonna make it super easy for people
to remember for people to find the new
agent boot camp it's pretty
self-explanatory where you're gonna get
in there and then it really took me
maybe like a weekend where I just sat
down for like Saturday Sunday in my desk
and wrote down exactly what I wanted to
teach what I wanted the outcome to be
for every single student that took part
I wanted to make sure that they all had
a great experience that they would tell
other agents to come back so that's kind
of how that happened it was like I
remember it was like a Saturday I went
on myself on canvas started coming up
with design so I did everything I was
like a one-man show
um and yeah that was the start of the
new agent boot camp
this video is brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
for streaming to YouTube and Facebook
with an incredibly easy to use interface
for built-in branding transitions text
lower thirds and seamlessly bringing on
guests it really is one of the best
options when it comes to live streaming
and what's so cool is they've
implemented a brand new feature called
local recording take control of your
audio and video with local recordings by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests this feature gives you the
control over your content for later use
making it perfect for podcasts and video
creators just go to streamwoodthink.com
to get started now
and so you're are you self-taught in
that regard your colors your logo your
name you came with the name canva
web software free version paid version
you just started doing the design did
you build out a landing page what
software did you use like people give
you their email yeah so it was on Wix I
just created a landing page for emails I
think I did create like some type of
form that people can put their
information on there but it wasn't
really that much I had no experience in
doing any of this I knew how to sell
homes I was a great real estate agent
but when it came to actually creating a
product in a course I'm like you know
what this is what I would do
um this is kind of what I see others
doing so let me try it out and aside
from that it was all just organically
through social media I put out YouTube
videos about it on Instagram and that's
how people started too so how did you
accept payment
um PayPal okay really yes so you're just
you're just like PayPal we it started at
497. everything was set up through the
website that I built so yeah it was
payments through there and then when I
say then you and then what did you
deliver where did you fulfill on this
boot camp
so there was a private Facebook group
um it was Zoom trainings every single
week everything was recorded everyone
has lifetime access to that aside from
that I would um if anyone had any
questions they could post it in the
group I would answer them in the form of
a video so that they can look back at it
in case you know they wanted to hear how
I said certain things and yeah that was
kind of like the the basic starting
package of what you would get and the
fact that they would be able to ask me
questions for many of them it was like
oh my gosh I have access to loida like
she's gonna answer my objection handlers
and anything like that that's kind of
what really sold it to a lot of people
that joined gotcha and so then where did
you upload the recordings from Zoom
the very first boot camp that I did I
did the recordings inside the Facebook
group so everything lived in there got
it in like the media area yes over time
it evolved to a Google Drive and now I
do have like funnels and all these
things set up so that everything lives
within like a membership and do you
still build that yourself or is it no
now I have someone else okay got it so
then as things have scaled as Revenue
increased you started to perfect things
yes I love that too because I think when
people are trying to transition from how
do you tune your knowledge and
experience into cash it can be super
overwhelming and it is a whole new skill
set to learn it could be email CRM
hosting membership developing if you
don't know what you're doing customer
service refund if you need to my credit
card got you know fraud and my payments
broke so now I'm trying to fix somebody
or like all these different details so
of course you got to start messy you got
to start really before you're ready and
I think you can level up as you go one
of the things we love is is really beta
programs when we first are YouTube
course main YouTube course is called
video ranking Academy and when we first
launched it it was
70 80 percent cheaper than it was now
because it was version 1.0
um it was also like we call it getmo
good enough to move on good enough
meaning it'll serve the client a
customer but it wasn't the final version
like get 1.0 out there into the
marketplace and if you're giving people
a lower price they're getting in early
and they maybe have future upgrades as
you continue to improve it and then you
gotta hustle and get cash because you
need money for the mission that you can
reinvest in people So eventually you
might have an assistant helping you with
customer service
um and you might have you know Heather
Taurus was critical in these early days
because even though I I am very familiar
I built WordPress sites and so we use
kajabi just the simple fact of building
like a landing page on an opt-in or
doing a web class yeah and then and just
a lot of different pieces so getting
help as soon as possible is is a is a
big deal for you how long did you run it
solo before you got help
like a year and a half okay so it was
still some time yeah so you ran a year
and then yeah are you thinking about
scaling right now are you thinking it's
you're at a good level with uh the
amount of help you have are you in a
process of thinking about hiring or more
yeah no continuing to grow definitely
got it so you're thinking team you're
thinking systems
um what other advice would you have for
someone again maybe the mistakes you've
made or the lessons you've learned in
the process of doing this that would
help someone watching that says okay I
am ready
I've got some experience and one of the
things I like to say too is you only
have to be one or two steps ahead of
others if you've been in real estate 12
months you probably already made 100
mistakes that you're like man I would
wish I would have known this day one
there's something about though building
enough credibility enough depth to at
least be a to be an intermediate to help
beginners eventually then that'll push
you to advance to help all the beginners
you help become intermediate and that's
kind of the customer Journey you know
Celine Johnson is one of my mentors as
well you just help someone who is where
you used to be and then you are also
continuing to grow exactly so if you're
continuing to grow then as they grow
you're just always a few steps ahead
which is critical that you would be
committed to growth to learning to
constantly learning I know you're that
way I'm that way we are always investing
in ourselves nevertheless you're just a
few steps ahead so if you uh are ready
to make that pivot what are some
mistakes what are some things that would
have helped you save some pain save some
time and that especially that first year
and a half I think for for this and also
just being a real estate agent get a
coach or invest in yourself in a program
or someone that offers exactly what you
want to learn and they're already doing
it yeah because if I would have done
what I did it took me a while if I would
have done it sooner I probably would be
at a much higher income doing other
things but I'm just now getting there so
I think that's the thing that scares a
lot of people investing in themselves
because a lot of times it's not going to
be cheap you can't find it on YouTube
there's only enough so information on
YouTube that's free but then after that
okay let's go who's doing what I want to
do that six seven eight figures because
that's who we need to learn from and
it's gonna cost you some money but it's
gonna take all of the pain away the
trial and error we're gonna get it right
from the start super smart yeah
investing in yourself it's the best
investment you can make if people want
to connect with you more where are you
on social media YouTube lloyda Velasquez
easy
um my website load of alaska.com and on
Instagram Loya velas